if you're looking for ways to outwork
everyone not care what other people
think and get over hurdles then this
video is for you once you taste some
success you realize it doesn't matter
how many times you failed right you only
have to be one right one time then
everyone's always an overnight success
or you know this came easy to them
there's nothing you can't accomplish in
life with the right amount of work the
challenge is you know are you willing to
do the work sometimes you've got to be
ready fire aim and just bust through
doors and figure you know you'll deal
with the constant you'll deal with the
regulation or regulatory issues later
need motivation watch a top 10 with
belief nation what's up it's Evan my 1
word is believe and I believe in you I
believe we have an amazing gift inside
you that I want to see explode out into
the world so let's take your motivation
to attend and get you believing in you
grab a snack and chew in today's lessons
from a man who went from selling garbage
bags at the age of 12
door-to-door so he could buy an
expensive pair of basketball shoes to
being a billionaire entrepreneur
investor author and TV personality he's
Mark Cuban and here's my take on his top
ten rules of success volume 3 enjoy
alright coming up first rule number one
is outwork everyone
most people do a lot of talking and most
people don't put in the effort there's
nothing you can't accomplish in life
with the right amount of work the
challenge is you know are you willing to
do the work and the reality is most
people aren't but that's the opportunity
right is I mean it's like people you
know at school most people are lazy
right they they just they barely get
through it and and so that creates
opportunity I tell my kids that a if
they want something they're gonna have
to earn it
yeah and B if they don't work hard
enough to earn it I'm gonna sell them
off as medical experiments that's the
line in our house you need money ok
we'll shut you off as a medical
experiment we can get you money that way
give blood dad I'm 7 I don't care so I'm
not so sure about the medical experiment
part but I love the fact that he's
talking about hard work is being the
opportunity if you do the things that
most people won't do then you'll get the
things that most people won't have it's
that simple
you gotta work next step rule number 2
go through the hurdles Steve Jobs said
it best everything's a remix you know if
you look at what Apple did they stole a
lot from Xerox they stole a lot from
different places and you know the early
days of of the PC industry software
industry there wasn't a lot of
regulation and it was just ready fire
aim you just went went went went when
you know now there's there's different
types of regulation my biggest myth as
an investor was because I paid too close
attention to disruption rme to
regulation so I had this guy send me an
email I first iodide finances last
company company called red swoosh what
did peer-to-peer file-sharing and he
sent me an email saying we're gonna
disrupt the cab industry and I'm like
that's a really good idea and it's like
yeah we're gonna call it uber cab
we're gonna go around and just use an
app so that people can hail a cab
that's why I called an uber cab so you
don't have to go through the the
intermedia of the taxi and I think this
is great but you're gonna have to fight
all the taxi associations and all the
transportation organizations in each
city in every state you know you just
you're you know and then I started
talking about his valuation and I never
heard back from him the rest is history
he's still a jerk but we're still
friends so you have you know and the
point is when you're trying to disrupt
something like Travis was doing right
you know and try it's got them in a
little bit of trouble particularly
recently but you know sometimes you've
got to be ready fire aim and just bust
through doors and figure you know you'll
deal with the constant you'll deal with
the regulation or regulatory issues
later and so you know he's obviously
disrupted transportation and he's trying
to do a whole lot more than that and he
gets all the credit because where I saw
regulation he ignored it and so if you
really believe and you really have
something that you know you think is
going to happen and disrupt the world
you know bring it to me I won't make the
same mistake twice and and then just go
and you know and bust through those
doors and figure out how to get through
the hurdles so one I love the humbleness
and I love how he shares a story of his
failure and that he's overcome that and
now it's a that past failure is a filter
for him to not make that same mistake
again I love it and too it's not just
regulation is everything when you come
up with a new business there's lots of
problems with it there's gonna people
who will poke holes in it everywhere
there's lots of ways why it's not gonna
work out if you only focus on why it's
not gonna work out then guess what it
never will but if you start focusing on
the one reason why it will work out and
go all-in on that that's when you start
to win let's go to rule number three
follow your effort
people are always all you're such a risk
taker I'm like I hate risk man I'm
terrified and literally it is terrifying
you know taking that first step for me
it was easier because I got fired but
you know it is really it's about
preparation you know if what we all go
through this process and tell me what
you think chase I mean where you've got
the idea right and you get that feeling
in your stomach and you get all excited
oh my god then you talked
friend and the Franco wow that's pretty
cool I never heard of anything like that
I'd buy that right and then you talk to
some other people and then you do the
Google search right anybody else has
anybody else doing this you tried 50
different ways no one's out there well
the first thing I'll tell you is just
because you don't see it on Google
doesn't mean 100 companies haven't gone
out of business doing the same thing
right
it may not be out there's the same
basketball you're open for a reason
which means you can't shoot so they're
not guarding you're right it hasn't been
done for a reason because every company
who's tried it has gone out of business
so the one thing I would tell you is be
careful but once you get past that that
stage then what I always tell people is
one is it something you love to do right
that is so true because it's gonna get
hard like just really hard it's gonna
get hard and if you don't love what
you're doing then it's like that when
[ __ ] gets hard that's when you're gonna
like oh man I'm gonna fall in the towel
right right because you don't know right
and you don't have a sense for it and
I'm a real believer that each and every
one of us has something we're good at
right and you've got to figure out is
this something you're good at you know
I've always been good at selling I found
out I wasn't into computers when I was a
kid then I found out when I start to
started to teach myself how to code it
was like I like this right and I
literally I would sit there writing
software and I think okay I've been
working two hours I better get something
to eat and it's been 24 hours you know
it's just like what the [ __ ] you know 24
hours I mean I okay tell me you're clued
in it's not just what you care about
it's not just passion because you should
let the circles overlapping passion and
aptitude right you weren't good at
something just because you love
basketball doesn't mean I'm gonna be any
good at it right yeah sure before I mean
you can have fun at it but if you're
trying to make a business a life a
living thing yeah I always say don't
follow your passion follow your effort
that's right so you might think you're
passionate about playing basketball
playing the guitar drawing design
whatever but where you spend your time
is your better indicator because that's
typically what you're good at and nobody
ever quits anything they're good at for
sure you know it when you're good at
something you you tend to want to get
better I'm not as bought in on this one
I think I've quit on things that I've
been good at but I didn't enjoy I think
it's possible to have aptitude and be
good at something but not love doing it
and want to go off and do something else
and by the same token I feel like if you
love doing something you
can get really good at it much faster
because you're willing to put in the
work and the effort and the hustle so it
still follow your effort but I think it
has to be matched for something that you
love it's a number one rule number one
rule in the book consistently which
includes cubed is he on the cover now
he's on the covers in behind the cover
he's not behind the cover but he's in
the book you have to do the thing that
you love and that will have to match up
with where your time is being spent if
you love something but you're not
putting in the effort then you have to
adjust your calendar to do something
better for you let's move on rule number
four create memorable experiences when
people think about going to sporting
events now use this as an example you
don't remember the jump shots after a
while you don't remember the homeruns
you don't remember the touchdowns you
don't remember the score you remember
the experience yeah you know remember
who took us to our first game with our
mom or dad
we remember how we felt when we won that
game you know going to a sporting event
it's one of the few places where you're
allowed to stand up and scream at the
top of your lungs and you're encouraged
to scream as loud as you want and
someone hits a game-winning jumper
you're hugging people and high-fiving
people you've never seen in your life
and you'll never see again and you're
walking out of the arena you know
singing and chanting and screaming and
if you lose that game you're bummed out
and you know the entire city or the
entire school can be bummed out so when
we sell when we seldom average we don't
sell basketball we sell unique
experiences and so you've got to
understand in your business exactly what
the differentiation is and what the
compelling aspect of that business is
but you know think about what you do as
a consumer what is it that makes you
make the choices that you make why do
you buy a certain thing why do you shop
a certain place why do you go to a
certain website those are the keys I
really love this one and it's something
we try to bring the Toronto dance also
to we're not just selling dance classes
but we're selling an experience and
people leave different more confident
more enthusiastic happy about their life
than when they walked in and it reminds
me of the Maya Angelou quote where she
says and I'm paraphrasing people will
forget what you did people will forget
what you said but they never will forget
how you made them feel and so if you
could change form your business to be an
experience everything from the first
phone call with you to the website to
the
know that they get afterwards the actual
using your service or product you make
them feel something that's when you
start to win time - rule number five
don't care about the opinions of others
most people really are concerned about
what people think about them it holds
them back you never ever ever ever have
it's not a part of who you are is that
your DNA or where did that come from I
don't know I just never gave ya it's
just once you get success in something I
mean even when look I failed many times
and you learn from those failures that
it doesn't hurt as bad as you thought
you know that you can bounce back and
then once you taste some success you
realize it doesn't matter how many times
you failed right you only have to be one
right one time then everything's always
an overnight success or you know this
came easy to them you know you just you
just got to keep on grinding and and
keep on trying new things and you know
once you start feeling the success you
realize look it doesn't matter what the
other people think other than my
customers other than my you know my
partners other than my employees I care
what they think
but you know from the outside looking in
I was always just so focused that I just
never I mean I got distracted from time
I don't want to say never distracted but
you know I just didn't want anybody else
I don't want to think that how people
saw me was a reflection of the job I was
doing you know if my customers were
happy
if the stakeholders were happy I was
happy I think if you want to stop caring
what other people think of you the
answer is not to read a book and how to
stop caring what other people think of
you it's to spend more time around
people like Mark Cuban's to spend more
time watching videos like this the more
you're in that environment of people who
just do their thing and they don't care
what others think about them the more
that's who you're around the more that's
gonna seep into you and that's gonna be
what you do so you may not have been
born with it maybe Kuban was born with
it and that's why he is the way he is
but if you want to bring that skill set
into your own life then I would start
watching as many of those kinds of
videos as possible to let it seep in
your mindset times rule number six be
passionate you're not like the regular
guy who owns a team who just you know
sits on the sidelines and his family
could you be involved to the other team
oh yeah if you try to get them assigned
with you don't decide you didn't sign
with me I'm like Mark Cuban is on time
with this oh yeah yeah I love it
I just think look you know I've been a
basketball junkie my entire life since
I've been five years old and um I just
get into it you know we all have
something right where you're just like I
asked all right just super passionate
right and that it's always been
basketball for me I mean during a game
I'm out of control right those 48
minutes right any other time I'm like
this I don't know about any other time
he's like that because I've seen him on
Shark Tank you can get super passionate
and I love it and I think you can never
accomplish anything great without a huge
boatload of passion you can't go off and
accomplish a big goal a big dream of big
vision without having insane passion and
bringing the people alongside you as
well we're passionate what they're doing
to know let's jump to rule number seven
do the work some people just they get on
the show and they think you know I don't
have to work anymore I don't have to
work as hard or if I get an investor
it'll be easier and it never works that
way or they just they stopped paying
attention to detail yeah right I've had
a couple companies where it's like all
right you know I'll hire people to do
all the work it's your company it's your
baby you've got to do you you know if
you're not gonna do the work who is and
I've always felt you know in terms of
leadership that my job is to put
everybody around me in a position to
succeed and if I'm walking around the
arena here I'm picking up junk on the
ground I'm you know helping customers
I'm trying to you know convey to
everybody that there's not a job that
you would do that I wouldn't do myself
and a lot of entrepreneurs that fail
they lose they lose track of that they
think you know I'm the boss I mean I had
a job one time and I was a horrible
employee where you know the president
the company spent more time telling me
how I should dress then trying to help
me close sales yeah
you know so you've got to do the work
and that's key you've got to be willing
to do every job in a company if need be
you've got to be everything from the
janitor to the CEO if need be doesn't
mean you don't want to bring on a team
but if need be you'll jump in you have
to work harder than anybody else nobody
else is gonna care as much about your
business as you nobody else is gonna
work as hard as you and if you are not
working hard don't expect your employees
to work hard nobody wants to work for a
boss who's slacking off period they
might first short amount of time they're
gonna go leave because they want to be
mentored they want to grow they want to
learn they want to make something of
themselves and they're not gonna get
that working for a slacker boss you have
to put in the work let's go to rule
number 8 be innovative again in 95 a
buddy of mine cam mica you know this
internet thing is starting to take off
there's no way to listen to sports on
the internet and you got to figure it
out you're the tech geek you got to
figure it out so I'm like okay we'll
figure out a way to put audio on the
Internet and so that's what we did and
so we started a company called audio net
started hooking up the technology
started going to all these different
radio stations teams and saying okay you
know you can't let anything outside of
Dallas anything outside of Pittsburgh
anything outside of wherever you can't
hear it or see it right now we want to
be able to listen like radio around the
world and they're like cool and so they
gave me the rights to their stuff and we
went started with the radio station in
Dallas hooked up an eight hour VCR had a
server set up in my bedroom and we
connected it to the internet figure it
all out and now I would just go online
to different places and say look if
you're interested in Dallas sports
download this go to this website called
audio net within a month we had
thousands of people downloading in a day
and this was like in 1995 and it just
got bigger no one had ever heard of
streaming then went from on-demand to
live to concerts to games to everything
to video and then we went public and
during the big internet boom and it was
the biggest IPO in the history of the
stock market and then Yahoo bought us
for 5.7 billion and then it up but Clara
was like was that like during the XM
satellite see like all of that satellite
all before that before that before they
were doing next time this is like
the idea of being able to listen to
audio or people are like what do you two
again like the Internet you and video
they had no clue and people were like
that's no one needs that I got a radio I
got a TV right and I'm like no you know
this whole audio thing Wow before they
had Digital Millennium Copyright Act we
used to work with with labels I remember
I was talking to Jimmy Iovine
and he goes and we're trying to get
music to put online and he didn't really
know what we understand it rightly and
so he goes mark forget about that for a
second I want you to listen to this talk
to this dude Marshall and listen to this
song and he puts on I am you know and
then I'm Slim Shady
yes let's ad right and it gets this guy
Marshall and he goes call him Eminem Wow
and so that's how we started working
with them to get on the you know
streaming on the internet with them and
we know the rest of the history on
streaming I know the name of this point
is being innovative and and he truly was
I think what I see from watching it is
just a combination of the market and
innovation with the passion like why did
he pick sports because he loves sports
because he loved Dallas sports so he can
make the conversations have their
relationships he wanted to get it out
there to the world combined with there's
a need there's an opportunity there's a
way to be innovative when you can mix a
thing that you love with where there's
an opportunity to market for that's when
you start to win let's go to rule number
nine read books I used to love to walk
through bookstores when there were
bookstores everywhere and if there's
something that caught my eye and I
thought he can give me one idea to spend
$30 to give one idea that could help
propel me make my businesses better it
was a bargain the only investment guide
you'll ever need by Andrew Tobias used
to get me all fired up
I read hours every day because all it
takes is one little thing to propel you
to the next level anything that you
think is interesting that relates to
business read it you know I I tried to
find books about entrepreneurs when I
was young I tried to find books about
businesses all my friends thought I was
crazy you know why are you reading this
why are you reading that and it's
because I enjoyed it so you know
regardless of you don't have to read the
right books if you read the things that
that are interesting to you then you'll
find things that you like to do
and once you find something you like to
do the goal is can you be good at it and
if you could be good at it then the next
goal is can you be great at it and you
know great things happen when you're
great at something
although the point I think continuing to
invest in yourself and learn is how you
get better it's how you escape your
current environment in your current
situation books are great I've written
two of my own but I think there's a lot
of ways you can learn now right you
could be through YouTube videos you're
watching this you're learning something
you're picking up from Mark Cuban
there's podcast there's just a lot of
other ways to learn as well and so I
learned primarily through video I'm just
I'm a visual learner it's how I prefer
to learn best so figure out like reverse
engineer how you learn best and then
plan time so that on a consistent basis
you're feeding your head with new ideas
with new knowledge with different
perspectives so that you can be the best
version of you all right it's time for
rule number ten our last field before
getting to the bonuses be a shark one
shark is out dave has two offers on the
table for his early education software
platform brightwheel however things have
become heated in the tank after Dave
suggested sharks go in on an offer
together you tell me what do you think
you need from the rest of the line here
are you serious are you really that
clueless nothing this time seriously are
you really that clearly I haven't heard
you speak up mark I'm listening right I
gave you a great offer somebody wants to
shot up right now they should because
I'm taking the Opera I just want to know
if we're gonna team up with anyone or
you either taking the offer so you not
even listen to you think
I want in with Chris Chris is gonna add
a ton of value oh no if anyone else
wants to join then do you ending
questions yes what else do you need from
somebody else and is anybody here
nominating themselves as bring something
the table I'm gonna need you to nominate
myself I'm listening right so I don't
need to convince Chris that anything I
have no problem with Chris and the value
he brings the other companies he has
right when he assigns his name to it
it holds a lot of street cred in his
little part of the world once you get
outside of that little bubble called
Silicon Valley it doesn't mean as far as
I know do you wanna if you want to
create a brand value so that somebody
who's working in Texas Pittsburgh Maine
Florida and wants to have an extra level
of confidence to say you know what this
was validated by somebody that we trust
something we know has a track record
your job gets easier
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed I'm gonna say rule
number four create memorable experiences
my personal favorite just because it's
applicable to my businesses especially
trying to dance all says we're trying to
move from not just teaching dance moves
but creating an amazing experience
everybody who comes in I love to know
from you do you agree is rule number
four your personal favorite or is there
one that's better let me know leave in
the comments below now I made this video
because Reese told parn asked me to so
if there's someone you'd like me to
profile in a future top ten video check
out the link in the description you can
go and cast your vote on the request
line and finally I want to give a quick
shout out to Michael from chart your
trade Michael thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my new book the top
ten rules to success and taking that
picture putting up on Twitter and having
it as an early Christmas present for
yourself I really appreciate all the
love and support man and I hope you
enjoyed the read so thank you guys again
for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon
my best business is you know solve
problems reduce stress make people's
lives easier because that's what we all
look for right in school you want to get
through class you want to get good
grades and you're looking for the best
way to do that when you start a business
you want to make your customers happy
you want to make it so that they don't
think about going anywhere else but
again you always got to think about your
own consumer experiences what is it
about what is it that you look for and
that tends to guide you
would you buy from your own company you
know and you got to be honest with
yourself because not all companies are
gonna be great but my most successful
companies understand that if you're a
true adventurer and you really want to
throw the Hail Mary you might take ten
percent and put it in Bitcoin or
aetherium but if you do that you've
gotta pretend you've already lost your
money and it's like collecting art it's
like collecting baseball cards it's like
collecting shoes you know something's
worth what somebody else will pay for it
it's a flyer but I've limited to ten
percent so how do we as innovators and
creators and everything about this
conference bring the country together
what do we do just be yourself
right I mean I agree with Adam you know
don't try to change one of the mistakes
I made an election as I tried to change
people's mind and that was a mistake
right just accept you know people are
going to disagree you know they have
their reasons but if you're a disrupter
if you're an entrepreneur if you have a
dream if you have a vision go out and do
it because when you know when you're
doing positive things when you're
creating positive results there are a
lot of people who benefit and you know
the wider you can spread it and the
bigger can get the better it is for
everybody raise your standard Apple at
the core it's core value is that passion
not one drop of myself work depends on
your acceptance of me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten roses success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link the description for details